e
and just a note to
um to all the committee members uh
you're going to get an email probably
today or tomorrow about next week weeks
hearing so uh we had four bills the
other day we have six bills today we're
going to exec these 10 bills total on uh
10:15 next
Wednesday and each party will probably
have their caucuses ahead of time but
we're going to start executing at
10:15 then after that we have seven more
bills on the
dock I've been kind of aggressive in my
chair my my clerk says make sure you
give me lunch today
so you know uh and my vice chair gives
me a note make sure you cover all the
bills and get them out in and out as
fast as you can so to do that I have to
be aggressive in the scheduling um so I
appreciate the committee and those that
testify bearing with us on that but we
have a lot of bills to cover so um for
those of you that are watching on tape
pay attention because uh we're going to
be voting on these six in the first four
next week just heads up thank
you so I've call up the prime
sponsor The Honorable Rosemary rung
resources thank you Mr chair and it's
such a treat to see some familiar faces
and some new faces um I'm very pleased
to um be here today to introduce House
Bill
332 um as many of you know I have been
um addressing issues around
cyanobacteria blooms for the last
several years and we've been successful
getting some passed into law um and I
want to dispel the
expectation that we can solve the issue
of cyanobacteria blooms or that we can
or state government can fix it state
government cannot solve this problem um
it alone it's going to take a
partnership with local individuals and
local communi
and that's the impetus for bringing this
bill
forward um we need to harness the power
of local folks who are directly impacted
by toxic blooms in their backyard and
their
neighborhood however it's not that easy
as most New Hampshire Lakes reside in
more than one
municipality so if one town passes a
lake protective ordinance it is far less
effective than if the other
municipalities pass the same this bill
empowers voters in those communities if
they want to establish a village
District to specifically protect and
mitigate and remediate surface waters
that they that are there first I want to
thank the honorable Dan Wolf who's here
um who first sponsored this bill last
year as a resident of Newbury which is
one of the communities bordering Lake
centi Dan recognized the need to allow
local communities to come
together to solve a shared problem HB
332 is identical to his 2024 Bill hb1
1250 it passed the municipal and
government committee last year but it
died in the house the in fact the ought
to pass vote failed by one vote New
Hampshire statute already allows for the
establishment of Village districts in
RSA 5 to colon 1 for 14 reasons
including and this is among some of them
extinguishing of fires the planting of
trees construction maintenance and
sewage of waste treatment sidewalks and
Roads recreational promotion and even
control of
pollen insects and pests and more HB 332
would simply add a 15th reason to
protect and M and remediate surface
waters why is this important each year
more New Hampshire Lakes suffer from
toxic cyano bacteria Blooms from Lake
winnipauk to babus Lake which is in my
town and we it's straddles Amherst as
well babus lake is not the economic
Powerhouse of lake wiip pasak or other
lakes in the state but it is important
to the residents who live there HB
332 would allow the towns of marac and
Amherst to form a village District to
protect babusek Lake but only if their
voters approve to
remediate the conditions that led to
these blooms by enacting ordinances
raising revenue for treatment and
whatever else is necessary to mitigate
blooms rather than waiting for the state
to do it HB 330 two is the ultimate
expression of local
control local voters get to decide if
they want this control maybe they vote
not to establish the district maybe no
one petitions to have that come before
the voters but if they do District
voters may not decide to do anything but
the important thing is that they are the
ones not the state who can take control
to improve the quality of surface water
in their Community please support the
passage of HB
332 to add this important consideration
to the rsas and to the other 14 reasons
Village districts can be formed um thank
you for your attention I'd be happy to
answer any
questions any questions for the
representative yes representative
Don nice to see you thank you Mr chair
um when you're looking at this specific
bill is this for any New Hampshire town
to be able to enact so for example I
live on canaby lake and so canab is
split by Windam Windham and Salem is
that what you're looking to say any town
can enact this or just in your community
you're looking oh no any Town any any
Town um maram and and also you don't
even need multiple towns for instance in
miramac we have a village District that
provides Municipal Water not even to the
whole town to to most of the residents
but if the voters of Salem and wind him
decide that they want to um have a
village District just looking at
remediating that surface water of canaby
Lake they can choose to um you know they
would have a town meeting an ability to
vote on a warrant article to approve the
district and then there is a process
already in the rsas where they would
then appoint or elect Commissioners to
make decisions and they would have an
annual meeting so for instance in the
mayor ma Village District which is our
water Municipal Water provider they have
an annual meeting every year um just
like a town meeting would do and where
um Commissioners are elected we vote on
the budget we vote on any Capital
expenditures or Bond issues so it's
really a subset of uh one or more
municipalities but it's established to
serve a specific
purpose I hope that answered your
question question representative thank
question representative
Taylor thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking the question how would this
work on Interstate Waters I have a
Province Lake in Wakefield Effingham and
Bonfield main it would only apply to
those communities it would only be an
option to those communities that are in
New Hampshire so there according to the
RSA you wouldn't be able B to have other
states communities form a district with
a New Hampshire Community would only be
representative
yes representative Derby thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
representative Rong um can you describe
um some uh policies that you think might
benefit um where cyan and bacteria
mitigation might benefit from uh a this
type of um board this type of uh
committee okay no thank you um well one
in particular is um and I'll use babusa
Lake as another example it has been a
chronically impaired lake with
cyanobacteria blooms um but it's very
small it doesn't have the economic
engine of Lake but it's very likely
going to need an in-lake treatment to um
really stop the blooming at least for
the duration of the the the
effectiveness of the Alum
treatment those treatments can run into
hundreds of thousands of dollars um a a
lake that I'm very familiar with lake
kisaka in molten burough I think it cost
upward of $500,000 for the lake
treatment this is an expenditure of
money that is very unlikely going to
come from the state for babusek Lake
there are bigger fish to fry more
economically um important Lakes like
Lake wiip pasak um lakes that Supply
Municipal drinking water that are
probably going to be higher on the list
for an an investment of an in late
treatment than babus Lake would but the
residents around that Lake if they are
in a district a village District they
may elect to raise the reeven to do the
inl treatment themselves um they may
vote to raise revenue that might match
State grant for the in Lake treatment
but it could also be something minor as
they may require septic you know
Shoreline septic systems to be pumped
every 3 years that's already occurred in
some communities um so it really depends
on what the specific needs of that Lake
are and where the um um the the source
of the Nitro nen phosphorus is coming
from and the expense of uh remediating
that um would fall on the district um in
in lie of the state another example is
um rebuilding a culvert you could be
something really is I don't want to say
it's simple but it's in the scheme of
things it's a simple remediation project
um that's something that the district
could elect to do if it helps um prevent
runoff of surface water that is adding
nitrogen and phosphorus to the lake they
may even raise money just to fund a
watershed management plan that would
identify all of these projects but it
takes away the Reliance on the state and
state funding to address concerns of
quality any other questions
representative n thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question thanks
for being here um is there a process I'm
sort of thinking ahead of the question
of someone opposing this is there a
process for disbanding this District if
it doesn't go well what is the what are
the sort of risks of this it's uh by
vote it's the same process as forming
one y okay by warrant article sorry uh
yeah it would be a warrant article of
the towns to disband the district okay
thank
you representative
V thank you Mr chair
um thank you for taking my question
representative Rong it's good to hear
see you here today um just basically
when we're looking at the word
remediation on line four does that
include all the Technologies or methods
that
a town or and this District would
provide
a oh it's um under one oh okay
oh uh protection and
Remediation so I'm sorry representative
could you repeat your question yes so um
the protection and Remediation of
surface water quality within the
district when we're talking about
protection and Remediation are we
covering we're covering prevention as
well as Technologies such as what was
used at late kosaka where they actually
attacked a bloom that was already in
forc yeah so it it really it's really as
it says whatever's necessary to restore
that late quality or to prevent
contamination it really just empowers
that District to make the decisions and
Supply the funding or seek funding um
that thank you for taking my question
question seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you one other comment I
forgot to make Mr chair if you'll allow
me um whatever the district decides to
do it still has to comply with state law
so for instance if a district decides to
do an in-lake treatment they still would
have to seek a surface water discharge
permit so it it doesn't exempt them from
complying with uh laws already in place
um at the state level it just allows the
district to it's mainly making the
decision and moving forward with
implementing that project
thank you thank
you speaking in opposition Steve wolf
New
London thank
you you have to turn on the mic there we
go thanks for taking the time to uh hear
my
testimony um I'm here today to in
opposition to making it possible for
petitioners to get Village districts
form for Lakes I have two primary
thoughts on this first off I'm sure the
folks in support have excellent
intentions to protect Monitor and
enforce the state's Lakeshore
development requirements however this is
already under the purview of New
Hampshire Dees and each Town zoning and
building
officials um all currently do an
excellent job especially here in the
Lake sunap Region where I'm from and of
course other citizens living on or near
our Lakes are sure to point out any
violations of sh land protection to the
towns and
de secondly Village districts are a bad
idea in general I currently live within
the extremely gerrymandered boundaries
of the Springfield New London water
Precinct this was formed decades ago to
provide uh potable water in accordance
with section
52.1 paragraph D the supply of water for
domestic and fire purposes which may
include the protection of the sources of
Supply focus on that a minute if the
village District decided to get the
domestic water from any Lake they could
prevent folks from swimming or boating
on that
Lake here in this Village District the
water supply is Wells on Colby point in
the middle of little Lake onip so no
restrictions currently on swimming in
this Lake now the interesting part this
Village District raises over 2third of
their annual
revenue by taxing properties within the
district and just onethird from actual
water usage charges if a property is in
the districts they annually pay a tax
based upon the value of their property
this year it was A110 per ,000 of assess
value so a $1 million house which is
very common in the lake snipy area um
would pay nearly $1,100 a year which is
collected by the town and then
distributed to the water
Precinct there are currently two large
Parcels of land in New London that are
slated to be developed for affordable
housing and Senior Housing and have been
paying that annual tax for decades to
the Village district and now the village
W not even provide water lines or
domestic water to these developments
citing a shortage of well
capacity and of course the groundwater
in New London's Central business
district is contaminated by posos so
private on-site Wells are out of the
question finally there are developed
properties within the district that have
private Wells yet those folks are
required to pay annual taxes to the
precinct as well in their 23 1/3 us
Revenue
collection set up and properties without
water Connections in the district can
never get
out or change the boundaries because the
select board in both towns would have to
agree to it and of course there are
always politics
between the folks that are running the
district and the select boards elected
officials and this is very prevalent in
New London and Springfield in summary
the establishment of Village District
dists for the protection and Remediation
of surface waters within the district is
a bad idea and just another major tax to
properties within whatever District
boundaries are drawn by those power
Brokers that can tax the heck out of
perpetuity and any questions any
speaker I don't see any thank you for
testimony yep I'll leave you guys copy
of
it thank
you apprciate thank you thank
you speaking in support of the bill
good morning chair harb and members of
the committee it's uh nice to see some
familiar faces here and some new folks
uh I hope to get to know uh the new
Representatives um on the
committee I am Andrea Laro the president
and policy advocate of New Hampshire
Lakes as many of you know we are a
Statewide nonprofit organization our
mission is to restore and preserve the
health of all of New Hampshire's Lakes
we uh work with Lake Associations
throughout the state on ways to um
restore and and improve the health of
our Lakes for everyone to enjoy we are
here in support of this bill I know you
have a long day ahead of you so I am not
going to reiterate all the excellent
points that representative Rong has
already
presented um what I will just a couple
of things I wanted to share and and I
think this might address some of what
representative veale was asking about
I've heard from a some a few folks that
um the wording here might be a little
bit vague for the protection and
Remediation of surface water quality of
course as an aquatic biologist I know
what that means and most of the people
behind me know what that means too um
but if if that is of concern to you um a
potential suggestion to uh reward that
to Encompass you know all the tools and
technology that are currently used uh
for this purpose would be something like
uh for the protection and restoration of
surface water quality through Watershed
and Lake management uh Watershed and
Lake management is is fairly well
defined um within the Department of
Environmental Services with various
programs and um some statutes related to
that as well so if you're concerned
about it being a little vague you know
tweaking it in that way might bring some
clarity uh the other thing I I passed so
you have a testimony uh letter from us I
see that we have about 150 Lake
Association folks signed in in support
of this bill and and many explanations
of why they think this would benefit
their Community again this would be a
voluntary enabling and may not be the
right thing for all communities but they
would have that opportunity to vote the
other thing I um shared with you is a uh
testimony letter written from Jack
cutner he is from the Save Lake ctie
shed and he called me frantically this
morning he really wanted to come and
testify in front of you and he worked
very closely with representative wolf
last year on this bill um you can't make
this up he's down in cabridge and his
garage is frozen shut uh so he's not
able to be here but um he quickly wrote
this up and um wanted me to give it to
you and I'm not going to regurgitate the
whole thing for you other than I if you
please I wanted to just share um one or
two sentences here to really capture why
this would be of interest and benefit a
Lake Community as a
whole um he said who in town government
has the expertise and accountability to
address these issues these issues of
protecting the lake ultimately this
responsibility falls on Town select
boards whose members are elected
volunteers that change annually and who
have very have large variety of issues
to deal with it's very difficult for
these boards to fully understand the
threats to water quality and to
prioritize action in the context of of
other
challenges um so what he's saying is
this Village District could have um
subject matter expertise um of folks um
Commissioners that that know um you know
how what needs to be done um in addition
I'd like to add this District could be
available um could receive Grant funds
um and other technical assistance um so
with that we urge you to support this
and I'm happy to answer any questions at
this time
any
questions I don't see any thank you for
much speaking in opposition Chris
Norwood representing the Realtors three
Norwood thank you Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Chris Norwood
I'm the 20125 vice chair of the New
Hampshire Association of Realtors and uh
speaking in opposition of the uh bill as
presented today um and I will kind of
conclude my uh with I will start with my
conclusion which is I think that uh
perhaps a study bill of Village
districts is more appropriate similar to
uh the bill that was um voted on
yesterday uh there was an ought to pass
on a similar study bill for zoning and I
I apologize I don't have the um uh the
bill number my my testimony is such that
certainly the Realtors care about uh the
quality of lakes it behooves us to and
important to our clients to keep the ca
bacteria blooms away from our lakes and
I appreciate representative rang's
testimony certainly I actually grew up
swimming in Lake uh babusek Lake um the
concern we have is with the New
Hampshire uh Village districts in
particular so in some of our research
and this is by no means conclusive there
are 91 Village districts in the state of
New Hampshire uh according to uh an
Excel file downloaded from NH
economy um the power that's vested in
them I'm going to read section 52 colon
3 Roman numeral 2 The District shall
thereupon be a body corporate in politic
and shall have all the power in relation
to the objects for which it was
established that towns have or may have
in relation to like objects and that
they are necessary for accomplishments
of its purpose and as the sponsor
mentioned there are about 14 purposes
for which Village districts can be
formed the realtor's concern is some of
these Village districts which the they
they've expanded in scope beyond for the
original reasons that they were formed
and I'll give you two
examples um the lighting District in
karge has some Powers relating to zoning
and Zoning enforcement and that can be
further uh researched because there's
currently uh or there was a Supreme
Court case the New Hampshire Supreme
Court case where um the karge lighting
Precinct was in a a lawsuit with one of
the the members of the property owners
within its
boundaries um that was up in Conway in
Northampton there's uh little borsh head
which is another Village District um
according to their website they were
established in
1905 and they have again according to
their website zoning
uh planning Board review essentially
they have expanded the powers in our
opinion beyond what it was originally
established for again according to its
own website little borsh head in
Northampton was established originally
for
water um we have no concerns over um
trying to improve the quality of our
Lakes but again according to New
Hampshire economy's website of the 91
existing Village districts nine of them
have Planning and Zoning Authority and
that seems to us Realtors as beyond the
original scope for which that they were
intended again Village karge lighting
District presumably hearkens back to the
days when there was you know oil lamps
uh lining the streets or something of
that nature um and why they have
Planning and Zoning Authority I we just
don't know and so the concern that we
have is the the expansion of the village
districts again uh if there is perhaps a
study bill they could look into the
village districts and to understand why
some of these Village districts going
back to the 1800s all the way till today
have expanded in their scope and
Authority we think that that would be uh
reasonable and uh I will entertain any
questions but thank you very much for
questions seeing none thank you for your
you speaking in support of the bill
Association is that work okay there we
go I'm Elizabeth Harper I'm the
executive director of the lake sopee
protective
Association um our mission is to
preserve and enhance the environmental
Integrity of the lake sopy Watershed um
so we work with all of the towns in our
Watershed there are um over five
municipalities that are trying to work
together to maintain water quality in
our area we have hundreds of members
that are interested in working
collaboratively to try to improve water
quality um with the record number of
cyano blooms across the state um the
capacity at the state level to address
the needs of all of the lakes and ponds
um in our state uh is stretched and
being able to address these issues at
both the local level and the state level
and doing that in collaboration I think
is going to be necessary to address the
problems that we are seeing currently
and that are likely to increase over
time we're in support of this bill
because it provides a mechanism for
those municipalities that have really
limited resources and expertise in these
areas to work together in a way that's
efficient and effective um so that we
can can try to address these issues
we've been working on septic regulations
with towns and having to do it with a
really peacemeal
approach um something like the village
districts would make that collaboration
and efficient use of resources um much
more effective um those are some of the
main points that I wanted to bring up
we've also been working with um
collaborators in New London um just
because that issue of groundwater
contamination came up I just want to
emphasize that um that is a a big issue
in New London it's not the problem is
not because of a village District um
that's not the root issue um that
groundwater contamination happened
decades ago it's a big issue um but to
say that that's the result of this I I
don't think is accurate um so I think
most of the other um key points have
been made by Andrea lamro and uh
representative rung so I'll um stop my
comments there but I would be happy to
take any questions any questions
representative Donnelly thank you for
taking thank you Mr chair um so have
you seen or or thought that this may
have actually have any limitations for
the rest of the state with using Lake
lakel uh cipe and is there any
restrictions have you seen with where
all of a sudden you're less people
across the state or even people coming
up to visit for just the day
this would create restrictions no not at
all I I don't see any way that this
would limit the use of of lakes for
recreation I think on the contrary you
know I think everyone in our community
understands what an important economic
driver our Lakes are and I think that's
really at the root of why we've been
able to get really widespread community
support for initiatives like this um
because every I mean our economy depends
on lakes being high quality as soon as
we have massive cyano blooms that's a
problem for everyone in our region and
they want to be able to work together um
to solve this issue so it's absolutely
the idea that it would prevent boating
or swimming is I I think
counterintuitive I think it's
specifically so that we can have lakes
where boating and tourism and swimming
are possible thank you thank
seeing none thank you for your testimony
I don't have any more pink cards is
there anyone else who wishes to speak on
HB
332 could be M representative will Dan I
have a pink card for 334 for you did you
bill okay
so we'll change the number and take your
seat Mr Wolf welcome back to
resources thank you maybe I should go to
Education
First um speaking in support speaking in
support thank you and thank the
committee for listening to me um this is
the same bill that was brought forth
last year it passed the committee I
believe it was 12 to 4 it got shot down
in in the house by one
vote this is not a control bill it is a
local control local assistance bill that
would put the ability to
coordinate environmental rules and
regulations together Newbury is part of
a village District on Lake Todd the lake
Todd Village District
which has a dam at the end of it and so
there's an ability for those people that
live on Lake Todd to maintain the dam
and tax themselves
Etc but when you have multiple towns
within a district you don't have
uniformity of Regulation the setback in
Newbury may be 250 ft it may be um 200
feet in New London Springfield will have
a different one this gives a mandate to
one legal entity
to coordinate all sorts of Environmental
Protections it will provide for
consistent regulation for the towns
within the
Watershed and consistent enforcement
with the rules and
regulations it'll offer the ability to
have prevention and planning for future
and as somebody said last year on the
floor of the house it does not provide
for any new taxes it is up to the
members of that Village
District to decide what they want it is
the epitome of local control if we want
to protect our watershed this is a
method for doing
it this bill does not form a village
District this is only enabling
legislation from here it goes forward to
writing the rules and regulations of the
district to the procedures that will be
employed to whether they want to allow
taxing whether they want to somebody
mentioned the lights in
kir it has to be all approved and it can
be modified this time or later on but
this is an enabling bill that allows
those in that those communities that
front on a Village District to enforce
actions on themselves if you're not in
the village District doesn't matter you
don't have the ability to enforce it I'm
asking you to prove this and if need be
modifications to my friend Steve Wolf
the the concerns in there maybe they
should be addressed but now is the
opportunity to attack those
various regulations that exist and I'm
open for questions happy to answer any
of
them representative Darby thank you Mr
chair um thank you honorable uh well for
uh for testifying can you um uh talk
about the concerns that were raised
earlier of the water districts usurping
uh zoning control from the local
municipality I think yes
I don't
whatever the town that approves The
Village District wants in there they can
put in there but if they don't want
zoning in there it they don't have the
right to do it if they don't want to
have uh Street Lighting in there they
don't have to do it it's a local control
that whatever the town wants they're
designating a village District to handle
a situation as we have in our Lake Todd
Village District it's taken the the work
of the selectman and the commissioners
of the lake Todd Village District
can a tax them because the town said
they could they can repair the desert
Dam excuse me and if there need to be a
draw down they can do it it does not
involve the rest of the town so I know
don't think you have to put what
there so representative I have one
question I just for the record are you
related to the prior speaker Stephen
will I I I believe he's with two fs and
I'm a one F okay I'm one F
oh are these years and I never knew that
we're just ski buddies and we do water
ski together
any questions for representative
wol seeing no more thank you
representative wol thank you and I hope
you'll give this due consideration thank
you now is there any more to speak on HB
332 uh one more time any other speakers
on HB 332 hearing none I close the
hearing on HB 332 and we'll start the
hearing on HB 334 FN in about 3 minutes
thank you
oh blue
sheet representative Dupont do we can
now have no cards on 34 or do you have
cards I don't have any cards for that
no you planned that out pretty well well
that one I did there's nobody here one
after that there's nobody here I don't
even see the sponsor
here which is why I'd like to make them
I don't know I don't know I don't
know I'm looking at the list this I know
yeah
e
thank you Mr chair um honorable members
of and colleagues of the resources uh
committee um I apologize in advance if
my comments are a little bit ad hoc I
didn't realize I was going to be
speaking on this bill today but I um as
a reminder this is this we this
committee saw this bill in the last term
I believe the last session um and it
passed um out of the out of this
committee um we heard last year that the
comprehensive uh uh State development
plan has not been actively updated um
recently and there was um the sponsor
had suggested that it was in uh in need
of an update in particular this bill um
talks about adding in um support for uh
recognizing the uh environmental needs
of to add environmental needs to the
state development plan and also um to
recognize environmental threats um I
have a couple of comments about those um
first the um uh Recreation um generates
over 325 million in tax revenue to the
state every year um uh I meant to say um
tourism generates over 325 uh million
and outdoor recreation in particular uh
generate adds 3.9 billion to the New
Hampshire economy that's as of um a
report that came came out at the end of
last
year a 2022 study indicates that for
every dollar that's invested in tourism
um we receive 12 um over $12 in tax
revenue so it's a very good investment
to the state clearly protecting the
environment and uh water is essential to
attracting visitors to the Lake Region
and the mountains and the um ocean front
and of course our beautiful um
forests um so this should be uh part of
the uh State development plan secondly
as this committee is very familiar with
pasas is pervasive pervasive across the
state particularly in the southern part
of the state but um has been detected um
as we just heard uh throughout the state
and and impacts Water Supplies
everywhere therefore Environmental
Protection um in order to uh M uh make
sure that we have the resources the um
clean resources water and air that we
need both for our residents and um of
course for a tourism industry
is critical in um and should be part of
um the uh the state development plan and
so um and this should not we should not
be reactive to the uh those threats um
and that's really what the second
section um paragraph 14 sub paragraph 14
talks about is um monitoring those
environmental threat so that we don't
have to be reactive I'll point out that
in addition to pasas um uh there's been
uh significant uh contamination with
mtpe throughout the state that has
costed uh you know the state and um and
uh uh well users throughout the state
lots of lots of consternation and we
want to avoid situations um such as
exist in um in Maine where pasas is
really um
uh significantly polluted Farmland even
to the point where as as an Outdoorsman
uh you can't even hunt on some of those
lands anymore because the the pasas
contamination is so impacted based on uh
uh the sludge the pasas and the sludge
that was spread as
fertilizer 90% of our W of uh
communities uh Community Water Supplies
have tested positive for uh pasas and
108 have exceeded um the uh pasas
mcls um and 46% of New Hampshire's on is
on uh private Wells so being proactive
with monitoring and um evaluating
threats to our public water uh affects
everyone in the state and can't be
handled at only a u municipality level
um so thank you very much uh for um you
know considering this bill I will remind
you again that um the it passed on a
bipartisan um basis last year out of
this committee and of course happy to
answer any
questions any questions for the
represent representative nav thank you
Mr chair thank you for pitch hitting you
did a great job um how often is the
comprehensive State development plan
updated my understanding from testimony
last year is it supposed to be updated I
think on a 10-year basis but has not
been and when um um when there was a
search for one of these it was actually
even hard to find it because it has not
been recently updated I I don't have
those numbers in front of me and I I I
don't have the my notes from last year
but I can uh get back to you with that
information representative ghoul welcome
okay thank you uh for taking my question
uh you talked mainly about water are
there any other things that are in there
that would be looked at besides just
that thank you for the question
representative gold um so the second SE
the sub paragraph 14 talks about
environmental threats um I talked a lot
about um water because that's what we
talk about in this committee but it does
specifically um call out uh waste
disposal and so impacts from landfills
for example um as well as chemical and
biological
contamination um I'd say that on the um
the natural resource of um um support or
um inclusion in this development plan um
it talks about lakes rivers EST Aries
forests Wetlands shorelands uh Coastal
marshlands so it is it's very
comprehensive I I really focused on the
parts um uh apologetically that are most
impactful to me and and that I was going
about anybody else for a question for
the
representative saying none thank you for
your testimony H thank you for your
time in support of the bill Andrea Lar
Lakes good morning again I'm Andrea Laro
president and policy advocate of New
Hampshire Lakes again we're a Statewide
nonprofit
organization representing uh Lake
Associations and Lake enthusiasts
throughout the state and we are here in
support of HB 334 and to um keep it
short uh we in support of it for all of
the reasons that representative Darby so
nicely laid out um ensuring the state
has a coordinated plan to guide All
State agencies will help Regional and
state agencies work together to restore
and preserve the health of New
Hampshire's lakes and rivers so they can
maintain a healthy balance looking
forward to the future
uh we you have all learned here the
threats our Lakes are facing and we we
don't know what threats they'll be
facing in the future so having um that
incorporated into the plan um my
understanding is that the plan has not
been updated for quite some time um but
there may be some interest in updating
the plan um but first um at least last
year the sponsor wanted to get this
added to the plan so that when the plan
is next updated hopefully soon uh the
threats to um these the provisions of
the bill would be included so I know
that was brief but uhu respecting your
time any
questions any questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you again
thank
you and the last card I have Elizabeth
Harper Lake sopy protective Association
bill hi I'm Elizabeth Harper from the
lake sopy protective Association
um and we're here in support of
334 um primarily because we think it's
important to have a proactive approach
to protecting our natural resources
they're fundamental to our economy uh
and we know from a lot of experience
that it's much less expensive to
proactively protect those resources
trying to remediate later um is
extremely costly um so for for many
reasons um it makes sense that a
proactive approach would be incorporated
into the state development
plan thank you any questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you for your
testimony I don't have any more pink
cards but maybe there's some coming so
I'll call out any more testimony on HB
FN for the second call anyone to speak
on HB 334 FN seeing no one approaching
the speaker table I'll close the hearing
on HB 334 FN and at 11:30 we'll open HB
393 FN and I have two cards for that at
11:30 thank you do we have a blue sheet
sheet representative Dupont will'll read
none
against okay thank you representative
11:30
e
let me say that again for the record I'm
calling the hearing on HB 393 FN to
order it's after 11:30
and to introduce the bill representative
Taylor
representative good morning Mr chairman
committee members on behalf of
Representative Jonathan Smith i' would
like to introduce House Bill
393 FN involving boat Mings others will
speak to the Bill thank you Mr chairman
thank
representative he's not going to answer
him
anyways speaking support of the bill uh
Patrol good morning Mr chairman
honorable members of the resources
committee my name is Tim Dunley and I'm
here this morning representing the
department of safety Marine
Patrol we uh we are in support of this
bill that you have before you today and
if I could just take a quick quick
moment to describe to you the issue that
has arisen uh new New Hampshire Law
requires on seven of our uh Inland
bodies of water uh there are uh if you
wish to uh place a moing uh in the water
to house your boat overnight long term
uh you are required to have a permit
Lake oopy in this case happens to be one
of them uh Lake wiip all our larger
Lakes winaki winam Squam Newfound sunpi
oapi bow and Pleasant Lake in
Deerfield we are seeing a phenomena
where uh boats are
employing devices uh from their uh boats
that allow them to be stored uh without
employing anchors or the use of a moing
and as a result this Niche device is not
fitting into the definition of a moing
and therefore they are slipping through
a loophole in the definition
essentially these
devices uh which you'll see in the
language is referred to as spuds which
uh are basically piles that are uh in
collars mounted to the sides of maybe
barges or pontoon boats that are dropped
into the water typically with a cable
system on all four corners and it holds
the boat in place we're also seeing
devices known as SE legs which is a a
brand name uh particularly on pontoon
boats where basically aluminum stilts
are bolted to the bottom of the
pontoons and with a hydraulic system
deploy these legs that lift the pontoon
boat up and out of the water along the
water's
edge and folks are using these when they
do not have a permit or are not able to
get a permit under the conditions that
the moing laws require and they're
leaving their boats on station uh and
right now it's legal because of the
loophole in the definition
this bill would simply close that
loophole many times particularly with um
property owner associations Lake
Associations condo
associations back property owners who
may live a mile away but have Beach
rights um are oftentimes by definition
are not able to get a moing they're not
assure front property owner and in the
case of maybe a condo association the
condo may have a 100 units
but governor and Council have only
approved them for say 20 Moorings based
on the width of their Frontage so folks
are employing these devices to avoid
getting the moing permit and still be
able to have their boat on our public
Waters we have a problem on um Pleasant
Lake in New London where people are
crossing town property the town library
and have Moorings in the lake in front
of other people's Shor Frontage but
because they can access the public water
without trespassing passing we we can't
do anything about it so this build comes
before you we are in support uh there is
one unintended consequence in the
current language and I've spoken with
representative Smith um as well as the
Marine construction industry uh they the
barges and the work that they do from
their their platforms for their
excavators and cranes and so on do
employ the use of the term spuds in the
definition and so uh we would suggest
that perhaps this uh Bill be amended to
exempt those Marine construction folks
who are engaged in trade and are on a
job site with the land a short front
property owners's permission to be
exempt from uh this this bill I'm happy
and would be welcome to entertain any
questions you may
captain representative Derby thank you
Mr chair I thank you Captain Den leave
you for taking my question um I want to
make sure I understand this bill
correctly um section one of the bill uh
extends the definition of appears to
extend the definition of moing to
include uh spuds and lifts and um and
then um section two um says that uh you
can't use spuds or lifts um in lie of a
permitted moing so what I think I'm
interpreting this to be is that you can
use spuds and lifts but you need a more
in permit to do
that that's correct and and uh it is
very obvious to uh boers and and uh
Marine
Patrol when a person is using these
types of devices on a sandbar for the
day uh to go swimming instead of
deploying an anchor that's an obvious
different intent and use of these
devices it's the fact that they are
leaving them on a routine basis over
night for the night
unoccupied um and in some cases for the
entire season uh that that we're looking
to uh
prohibit H up thank you Mr chair um
thank you again for taking my
question
um you just pointed out the the concern
that I've heard among some fishermen uh
bass fishermen that use um sometimes
they call them spuds sometimes they call
them um some other things but they
basically are the same thing they
basically plant the device I don't in
reading the text of the RSA I don't see
anywhere where a moing is for overnight
and so um I wonder if there needs to be
some clarification that this doesn't
affect those categories that you just
described which are um you know people
more you know people effectively
anchoring for the day but using these
devices to anchor for the day or in
particular fishermen that are just like
setting up outside of you know show you
know sh or something like
that thank you for the question I I
think a simple um uh use of the term
occupied uh would make all the
difference in the world uh and and
Define if you want to Define occupied as
as uh the boat's owner uh or occupants
being within a certain distance of the
boat whatever we may come up with um
certainly clears that up uh there are
there are laws already um on our books
that prohibit overnight Ming uh and and
devices any
questions I have one Captain you
mentioned a perhaps an amendment to
exempt Marine construction I know when
we deal with the do they always want an
exception for any state Vehicles doing
any work and if what if they're out
there working on dams or something
should that um Amendment include some
State Mr chairman absolutely that would
be fine um we we've done that with uh
seasonal platforms that came before this
committee a couple of years ago where uh
we Exempted folks who were engaged in in
Marine construction uh Bridge work even
doing biological studies and surveys uh
of our water conditions so that
certainly uh goes beyond the intent of
of this bill uh and perhaps even
mentioning so that that there is no
confusion although the permitting uh
requirements are different uh we may
want to say instead of um public Waters
mention Inland Waters because as we know
the Sea Coast and Moorings a whole
different a whole different game uh on
our Coastal
Waters thank you anyone else have any
questions thank you Captain appreciate
time in support of the bill Judith
Ericson
homeowner uh thank you honorable members
for taking my comments um Judith Ericson
my husband and I are part of a family
trust that owns property at 60 de Cove
Road o New Hampshire and our neighbors
the buzzells are also joining us in my
comments uh r2d s have an easement in
favor of people behind us who
historically came to the camp before the
houses were sold individually and so
they have an easement of 8 feet to the
beach this does not qualify them for a
moing but one of the people behind us
has been using the integral Boat Lifts
to park his boat for the entire season
in front of the
easement he knows he can't get a moing
permit but he is happy to tell you how
smart he is uh in getting around the
moing
laws so our concern is that he has also
stated his intent to acquire more
property and park more boats there we
also observe that there's a
proliferation of boats on sea legs
around Lake
oapi you know when someone has one moing
you can tell pretty easily that they've
got another one outside of the
regulations but there's a lot of condo
associations and it's in those areas we
see a lot of proliferation of boats on
sea
legs you know seven Moorings 10 Moorings
who's counting it's hard to enforce
that we're also concerned that we know
our neighbors have been historically
renting out their docks and their
Moorings and contrary contrary to the
regulations partly because the property
taxes on beach FR property are really
high and so we fully expect that people
would try to offset their property taxes
by either renting their docks or in this
case renting their beach access because
really as long as you have access as the
St state policeman said in the case of
the library C Crossing anyone could put
a boat on sea Lakes anywhere in the
water so long as they can walk through
the water to some access and so if
people decide to allow that access and
the this situation is not covered by the
moing law then really any number of
boats could be anywhere and that's our
concern so we don't in any way want to
hamper Fisher people fishing at all
that's not our problem our problem is
with the boats that we see consistently
parked for the entire season on sea legs
next to the shore sometimes in front of
other people's property um and that's
the situation we would like to have more
uh fully captured in the moing laws
which is the intent of the law is to
regulate and limit the number of boats
and to keep it safe and the more boats
there are the more traffic and
collisions there's likely to be so we
support a change in the law to include
this situation as a moing so that it can
be
regulated thank you very much thank you
any questions for our
speaker don't see any thank you very
you and my last pink card also speaking
in favor but suggesting an amendment on
New Hampshire
Marine trades Association Jody grimas
Jody
thank you all um my name is Jody grimus
and I represent the New Hampshire Marine
trades Association the Marine trades
Association is a is a a business group
dealer group uh the marinas boat dealers
across the state belong and work towards
the benefit of our lakes and the
industry um we saw this bill and had
talked to Marine patrols didn't have any
concerns about it but we did get a
concern as as um Captain Dunley said
from our marine contract contractor U
members uh one of the members couldn't
be here today so he asked me just to
bring up we'd love to see the amendment
that's being talked about um when
they're doing work on someone's property
they use these spuds for their barges to
bring out the various equipment and um
expertise that they need to make those
fixes and they feel that this would
potentially um prohibit that and that
would be a concern for them so if
there's a way to make sure that we're
carving out that commercial application
um we would ask that be
considered thank you thank you Jody any
questions for the
you and if I could ask Captain Don Levy
since you're still hear a question who
do you think's going to be submitting
the
amendment or did you
know so right I don't know uh I had a
conversation with representative excuse
me representative Smith who was
absolutely open to the idea but there
wasn't any conversation as to how that
would come how's it going to come about
okay just but if there's any way we can
provide some assistance certainly let us
know okay thank
you I have no more pink cards anybody
yet yeah for the record jod gribler said
she'd be happy to work with the captain
and then maybe the representative that
made the initial presentation so that we
could have an amendment remember we're
going to exact this bill in a week so it
would be nice to get that in so we can
talk about the amendment next week thank
you both um seeing nobody else
approaching the speaker's uh desk or
filling out any pin cards I'm going to
declare the hearing on HB 393 FN closed
and we'll return at 1:00 for the hearing
on HB 422 FN can we just get the blue
sheet and the blue sheet
again representative
today 54 none against okay thank you
representative and that's it so we'll
little
e
thank
you good afternoon it is uh after 1
o'clock I'm going to call uh the hearing
on HB 422 FN to order and uh our Prime
sponsors here with us again
representative
Ron thank you very much Mr chairman and
committee and um just for the record my
name is Rosemary rang I represent
Hillsboro 12 which is the town of
miramac and this may be a jinx but HB
422 is essentially a housekeeping bill
um back in 1991 when the Shoreline water
quality protection act was put into
statute it called for a
$5,000 um fines and
it understanding um and observing what I
do in The Lakes Region when I'm there um
$5,000 really isn't a deterrent um
people spend that on the drawer pools
for their kitchen so um I went into the
Department of Labor Statistics has a CPI
calcul
to um find out what that 5,000 would be
in today's dollars and it comes out back
in November when I ran the calculation
$1,796 so when I was drafting this
legislation I rounded that up to
15,000 and it still gives um Superior
Court Dees they don't have to go that
high it's just raising the ceiling of
where they can go
and as I mentioned in the the um uh as
I've mentioned before a lot of times
this this types of legislation it's not
an um one of the purposes of it is also
just to drive a culture of Lake
stewardship so when people see wow this
is a $155,000 fine um or I I can't do
this anymore it is it creates a a
culture where people are going to take
more individual responsibility um for
their behaviors around lakes and if they
know that wow I could get hit for
$15,000 if I do this it's it's a
stronger deterrent than 5,000 is and
that's really what this is doing it's
really trying to draw a line in the sand
that violating the shoreline water
quality protection act is not something
that is going to be facilitated or
acceptable to the state that it's
important enough to comply
that if you don't comply there's going
to be a lot of negative repercussions
and one of them is that you're a risk of
$155,000 so I'd be happy to take any
questions any questions for the
ghoul okay sorry about that thank you
for taking my question and uh somebody
asked me actually to ask you this type
the question uh maybe the person does
not know you know the laws involved here
but for example if there were leaves
near the border of the
water or the person put in a rock to put
a so that Turtles can go on the Rock and
and
sunbathe um if say you had a neighbor
that didn't like you very much and they
said oh you know they're doing something
is something like that applicable to all
these laws or
not yeah I I'd have to review the
shoreline water quality protection act I
know that we have a there is someone
here from Dees Darlene Force who could
probably she's here to answer any
questions if anyone has so she could
probably address that um but as far as
you know having that that neighbor
interaction I know that if there is I
know many people that live on lakes and
if they were seeing a neighbor starting
up a chainsaw to clearcut their their
boundary with the wad their
Shoreline they would say did you know
that's against the law and and you could
be finded just an Administration find up
to $155,000 that person may not even
know but it does like I said establish
that culture it gives Lake stewards an
opportunity to reiterate to their
neighbors that um there's penalties for
violating that act um and I think
$155,000 gets people's attention more
than in today's dollars than $5,000 does
I don't know if that answers your
question but there's different things in
the shoreline protection act and and as
I
said I would expect that if Dees was
called on a complaint like that they
would exercise good judgment on what's
valid this isn't um compulsory on the
part of the department or the courts to
issue it they still could they could
wave a fine um but it does give them
latitude to go higher than the existing
um fine limit does thank you thank you
thank you for the question any other
questions representative thank you Mr
chairman thank you have there been
violations in the past where people just
wanted it like it was worth pay a000
um I would I would ask Miss Force to
address that but anecdotally I do know
of one situation where um a a lake
resident he was allowed to build his own
septic system design and build his own
septic system um and we've last term we
actually changed the law to disallow
people from doing that you know that had
to be approved by Dees and it was
draining on his neighbor's property but
it that neighbor spent tens of thousands
of dollars on legal fees and finally
after a few years Dees came in and did
fine um and under that current law he
was allowed to do that I think I forget
what it was um representative you
remember we we used to allow licensed
contractors to be B to design and build
their own septic systems and oh you had
to be a New Hampshire resident and that
went away but when it was still in force
this person definitely flaunted it and
he did get he did get fined but it took
a while and it took a lot of money on
the part of the neighbor in private
legal
fees yeah thank you for the question
anyone
else seeing none thank you repres thank
you and I I have my written remarks with
y
and support the bill Elizabeth Harper
Lake sopy protective
minute hi my name is Elizabeth Harper
I'm the executive director of the lake
sopy protective Association uh and our
mission as an organization is to
preserve and enhance the environmental
Integrity of the Lake sopy Region um the
sh Shoreland water quality protection
act is an incredibly important tool in
protecting water quality for lakes ponds
and streams
um I I think representative DuPont's
question was a good one and I can tell
many stories of sort of how these
penalties are perceived in in our
Watershed and in our Lakes um I've heard
contractors and homeowners refer to this
type of a fine of $5,000 as the cost of
doing business um I've had people with
very good intentions who are even
members of our organization and want to
do the best for water quality who have
said well if you want to cut down more
trees you just have to pay a fee right
so so they don't understand that it's
illegal and that they're actually being
fined because something's illegal so um
adding more teeth to this by increasing
the penalty makes it so much easier for
us to educate the public and everyone
that we're working with homeowners
contractors zoning board planning board
members um about the fact that this is
really important and to have the backing
of the state to say yes there are fines
and this is a penalty it's not just a
fee that you can pay if you want to cut
more trees down um I think is very
important um so we're in support of hb4
22 um to increase the
penalties any questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you very much
thank you also in favor Andrea Laro New
good afternoon uh nice to see you all
again I'm Andrea Laro president and
policy advocate of New Hampshire Lakes
um as you've heard our mission is to
restore and preserve the health of our
Lakes we're here to speak in support of
this bill um I would we are in support
of the bill for all the reasons that
representative rang and and Elizabeth
Harper uh just shared with you and I um
just wanted to point out that this would
just enable the Department of
Environmental Services to fine up to
$515,000 uh we understand and appreciate
that the department really doesn't like
to fine folks they really like to do an
education first approach um and my
understanding is that the department
would work very closely with someone who
um violated the law because maybe they
didn't know work with that person to
help uh correct the problem without
finding my understanding is that it
would be helpful to the department to
have potentially an an increased fine to
um work with those folks who um don't
cooperate with the Department um we and
so in in some we do think that providing
the department with the ability to raise
doing an increased fine would serve as a
deterrent uh to more folks to knowingly
violate the law and to re reiterate what
Elizabeth Harper said we are aware
Statewide of organiz a reporting to us
instances in which um folks may not be
deterred um because they think it's just
a a fee they might get assessed for
doing something not in compliance with
the act so with that we urge you to
support this um housekeeping Bill any
questions any
questions seeing none thank you again
I don't see that you filled out a pink
card did you want to speak or you just
questions if there are any early
enforced Dees I'm the Department's not
taking a formal position but we were
happy to answer questions if anybody had
them do anyone have a
question representative Darby thank you
Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um sorry and my questions um can you
give me examples of how frequent or can
you let me know how frequently the
department currently um uh issues
penalties or fines I guess for violating
their Shoreline protection act as
opposed to uh working with the homeowner
situation uh the last time that I'm
aware of us imposing a Shoreland fine
was in fact in 2013 this body helped us
to correct a flaw in our fine Authority
last year that modification to the
statute which will allow us to find
people again went into effect on January
1st so we haven't exactly had a lot of
opportunity um but it is because finding
someone does not actually achieve an
environmental outcome it does not
improve water quality as we testified
last year our purpose for fines
is leverage when we have someone who is
not compliant frequently it
is if you do not comply this would be
the fine the fine is held in
abeyance that would be the standard
policy for the way the department
typically uses findes and other programs
anything representative
Taylor thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking the question does this have
Dees I'm not sure what you mean by
restoration cost to Dees uh that
mentions a party not uh uh conforming to
do restoration they may be fined so I
assume that Dees would go ahead with
those Restorations and seek restitution
am I mistaken Dees does not have the
capacity to conduct the restoration
ourselves we would typically require
that the person who committed the
violation completes the res sub submits
a restoration plan for approval and then
completes that restoration where fines
would become a factor is if they refuse
to submit a restoration plan or refuse
to engage in res uh in restoration or if
the Damage Done is
irreparable so it doesn't affect any
cost on restoration to
us thank you thank you representative
donelly
thank you Mr chair you just mentioned
that in it was back in 2013 was the last
time
you gave a fine out for
$5,000 uh 2013 was the last time we find
anyone anything in
Shoreland so I guess my question is do
you feel that increasing this will
enable you to find more people
it will not make any difference in our
ability to find people it's just a
matter of the size of the leverage that
we can bring to B in the future when our
ability to if it becomes necessary to
use that leverage it's a bigger
questions hearing none I'll go back to
representative Darby thank you again
again Mr chair thank you Miss forest for
the question taking my question you
mentioned that um the cases I think I
understood the cases where um DS would
um find is um if the if the owner uh
refused to perform the restoration or if
the damage was irreparable so can you
describe an example of the irreparable
damage that where where there would be a
fine
which is a little bit difficult because
we do have some Active cases so I'll
generalize
um where you are dealing for instance
with steep
slopes
and an
[Music]
individual who had the ability to retain
Woodland buffer and who had a permit for
a limited amount of clearing to replace
and rebuild a home might say exceed
their
clearance um not maintain proper
construction or stabilization practices
lose control of their slopes Wipe Out
the entire lot work through the cease
and desist orderorder for eight
months
um
and possibly violate the consent
agreement a year later would be a nice
opportunity to have the extra leverage
to
say this could become costly if you
behavior anyone
else thank you appreciate you
testifying I have no more pin cards is
there anyone else to testify on HB 422
FN seeing none I'll close this hearing
and at 145 will open the hearing on HB
you
e
uh it's about 1:46 I'm going to open the
hearing on HB
449 requiring water districts to provide
a water filtration system to residential
customers in certain cases and I call on
the prime sponsor representative Maguire
who's going to talk to us today thank
you Mr chairman members of the committee
for the record my name is Dan Maguire I
represent the town of Epsom and this
bill is result of situation we have in
Epsom but I didn't write it just for
Epsom because uh I wrote it in a in a
more General way because I can't imagine
that
somehow you know the other
250 um communities in the state there
might be someone who finds themselves in
in a similar situation and would could
make use of this so here's our so I'll
have to tell the story of what's going
on so um gen epsom's about 5,000 people
which means we have maybe
2,200 households and of those 300 are on
a water district and the rest all have
individual Wells so very small part of
the town maybe 15% or so or in this
water district and it tends to the
smaller more compact area of town and
this particular water district has uh
two Wells that they pump water from one
is next to Route four so um and and I
don't know what they have 50,000 cars a
day or something no problems at all the
other well is next to our school and and
it's been testing um a little too high
for
pasas so um it it apparently the the um
limit on P is 12 parts per trillion and
this well is right around there
something in the so it's been failing
the past test um and when I asked
Dees why is the one near the busy road
no problem and the one near the school
when there's never been any industrial
activity failing for past they said well
we we really don't know maybe they wax
their floors too much you know in the
school so um so that's one problem and
um and so the question is what to do
about it and um
basically um Dees there's there's a
slightly there's a slight complication
because um this particular well and its
wellhouse doesn't have room for the P
filter FF filter um would cost roughly a
million dollars and it's pretty s able
and so and the other problem is this
particular well is in an area where 20
years ago we had a flood and the flood
caused the river to change and rather
than put a dam in to put the river where
it used to be the river was allowed to
meander somewhere else and the ne
consequence is this well is now in a
flood plane okay that it it it didn't
used to be in but but it is now and um
so it's not it shouldn't that should be
fixed too right I mean the the wellhouse
the pump house for this well should
needs to be moved elsewhere because it's
in a flood plane so um the ne so the
proposal um from Dees to the to the to
the water district is um build yourself
a new pump house up the hill somewhere
else reroute the pipes to the pump house
and back to your water system put make
the make the pump house big enough to
have all the P filtering bottom line $6
million okay um well $6 million for for
300 customers that's a lot of money
right that's 20,000 a piece um and and
what Dees says is we'll lend you the $6
million 30-year mortgage low interest
Etc and we will forgive 60% of that loan
because we got Federal money we got
State money we got various things and so
your cost for this is only 2 and A5
million so that's not bad right and but
if you look if you work out the numbers
the people in this particular water
district normal their normal water bill
today is roughly $100 a quarter and that
would go to something between $200 and
$250 a quarter right so we're talking
about more than a 100% increase in their
water bills and they're understandably
uh not happy about
that um and so what the purpose of this
bill is to give them an alternative
because when you when I asked Dees so so
the way this works is they would have to
borrow the Six Million they would have
to vote to borrow the $6 million right
so the the people who were in this water
district they have an elected board and
that sort of stuff so they have annual
votes so so the board will propose to
them let's borrow the money and here's
the consequences and so on but the
question is what happens if they vote no
right because now you've got a
non-complying system with the pasas uh
not quite meeting the pasas requirements
and it's in the flood planing and so
according to De what happens in that
case is they shut down the system they
basically take the system system away
from the elected board give it to
somebody else the somebody else will
borrow the money and and then charge the
people for the $6 million you know the
same deal but but it would happen so
basically they're given a vote but it
doesn't matter which way you vote
because at the end of the day it's going
to happen the way the way Dees wants it
that's that's the state of the law today
as I understand it so this bill is to
give them an alternative so
what's expensive about this partly is
moving the wellhouse out of the flood
plane um and that may or may not be
urgent right it doesn't it's been in
this same spot for decades and working
okay and all that but the also the P
issue and um and the problem is it's
it's expensive to to uh reduce every
drop of water coming out of this well to
12 Parts less than 12 parts per trillion
of pasas right so so and and it's only
crucial for what you drink right it's
it's what you drink that counts you
could wash your car with it as is you
could you know wash your clothes your
body water your lawn all this sort of
stuff with the water as it is perfectly
fine so what the bill says is if you
find yourself the situation where your
water is not portable right so you can't
drink it but it's otherwise okay and you
vote not to you not to accept a a fixed
solution proposed by
Dees then you'll have an alternative
which is that you buy everyone in your
all of your
customers a um a filter for their
kitchen right for their drinking water
and their cooking water that would solve
the problem for that water so so we
estimate in this case that that instead
of a $6 million cost the the cost of3
such filters that would only be good
enough for drinking water and not for
every drop of water that would be under
a million dollars so it'd be much more
cost effective and so at least
the the the point is um if the bill
passes at least they have a choice right
they can get the
fullblown $6 million solution or they
can get this other solution and I don't
think that this solution U with the with
the individual filters is so horrible
because it's exactly what I have at my
house and have had for close to 20 years
right because the water that I get from
I have an individual weal but the water
that comes up from it is not it doesn't
meet drinking water standards as as they
exist today and so I have a I have a
water softener that keeps my my Plumbing
fixtures from looking orange but I also
have a drinking water filter in my
kitchen because I I you know I don't
want as much arsenic or whatever it is
that's that's in the water so so this is
a common sort of situation that that
I've lived with for you know like I said
close to 20 years I'm sure many many
other people do the same thing anybody
who has an individual well has to have
uh you know drinking water filters so um
so that's all we're asking we're say
sort of saying let's give them an
alternative because the costs as you
know over time these these these
requirements are getting stricter and
stricter and guess what the cost of that
goes up and up and and eventually you
know it gets Una affordable so I'm happy
to answer questions representative na Mr
chair thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um my town has past I
have a past filtration system in my
house so um my question to you is yeah
if you make this requirement that the
water district has to put this
filtration system in the house but
there's no requirement that the
filtration system is serviced from that
point forward aren't you sort of taking
away the water system from those 300
houses because in a year it's on them to
test if they're if they have P pass if
the filtration system still working if
and if they don't service it ever
there's no guarantee about their water
quality so you've sort of made your
water district defunct I understand
through this thank you for the question
so um I'm going to ask you a question in
a moment because I I'm curious how much
you paid for your home system but anyway
um here's the the here's the thing um a
water system for a house house uh
consists somewhere of a well a pump who
gives you pressure and some kind of
filter right and so um what this bill is
sort of saying is it's
okay if all that stuff isn't necessarily
of industrial size and part of owned by
the Water District right it's okay if
what The Water District is providing you
with is pretty good water but not
absolutely perfect water right not
drinkable water necessarily but it's
it's good you know I mean like I said
you can use it for 90 95% of the uses so
so
um and and so the people that have this
system and would have to maintain it
themselves would be in the like I said
exactly the same situation I'm in and
most of my town is in um so I don't I I
just think yes they're not getting the
exact same service they are now right
but they're getting pretty close to it
and
um I don't think that's
unreasonable follow thank you so I guess
my question back to you is is it okay
because what are the laws around a water
district and what are water district is
providing is it okay for them to be
providing water that is essentially
nonpotable well it would be passing them
I believe right so that's what this says
this says that's okay right so this
would be part of our law Etc so I I
think it is are you saying if if you're
if you're
asking is there some other area of law
that this bill should also change right
that says except for
RSA whatever it is 31 Golding
139 um I don't think so I mean the
drafter didn't find such a section so
but maybe you're right I don't know so
maybe I'm sorry do you mind one more we
have to move on so so I guess I'm just
so maybe that that is missing because it
doesn't seem to me that this legislation
gives you the right to now offer people
a lower quality of water and that seems
like what you're you're going to have a
water district that provides water that
is potentially not passing Dees
standards and I don't see that in here I
I see that you're going to provide a
filtration do option to have inhome
filtration systems rather than a water
district filtration system that is not
then service going
forward yeah again thank you for the
question but but I think this does say
that the situation is okay and um if it
isn't then you know I'll work on an
amendment or or something but um but my
point
is it's we're we're trying overall to
get people to drink drinking water at a
reasonable cost right I
mean you can't people don't have
unlimited amounts of money so they they
they need to get water obviously they
need to get water to drink obviously but
but the overall cost ought to be as
reasonable as possible right um and and
my experience with my own home system is
I do have to maintain it myself I do
regularly have to change filters and
clean it and things like that but but
it's it's at least with my filter it's
fairly obvious when I have to because
the the flow rate of water gets lower
and lower and you have to do it or you
can do it just on an annual basis but
but it's it's perfectly doable it's like
maintaining anything else in your house
right I mean you got you got the water
heaters you got furnaces you got etc etc
lots of systems in a house that need
maintenance so I don't think it's
unreasonable representative we have a
speaker the next speakers from uh Dees
and I think he might be able to address
your question specifically
representative
Ryan thank you for one at a time one
thank you okay
um do you water your garden with the
nonfiltered water yes but my I
don't um so first of all well the water
that comes into my house is goes through
a a pretty serious um um what is it
called water softener right so the stuff
that comes into my house is heavy iron
and other stuff so it would be orange
and all that but that is the water that
goes to hoses and and things like that
so um you know I mean there's just it's
the characteristic of the of the
groundwater that's what it is
um but I personally am not a gardener
much of a gardener so you know I mean I
don't I'm not growing tomatoes or
whatever you had a followup thank you um
a a totally unrelated question what what
do you propose would happen if there's
new construction in your
town um do they are they going to have
to be provided with um a filtration
system in their house or yes how do we
deal with this in the future down the
road yes thank you for the question so
there's there's this area of town is all
built up so it's it's essentially um
unlikely that there will be many new
customers coming onto this particular
water system Unless somehow it was
extended somewhere else but um and so it
would be a s similar
situation to again somebody building a
house right somebody building a house
has to test their water has to to put in
a system that that works for it and so
on right so so again the the people who
would hook up to this system would say
oh you know this this water and and part
of the bill I think says they have to
tell you that the water is not drinkable
on a fairly frequent basis and so um
anybody who built a new house that
happened to be connected to the system
would know that yes I'm I'm I need to
house U representative Taylor then
representative thank you Mr chairman
thanks you for taking the question
what's going to happen with the high
school and other uh nearby town home
facilities yes thank you for the
question so uh it's not a high school
it's a elementary school but yeah and
there are some businesses the way I
wrote the Bill is for commercial and
Municipal
facilities it's up to them
to um to add whatever filtration or
other solutions they want right they
could go to bottled water they could
they could go to um individual filters
they could go to a a filter for their
whole facility but I put I put this on
them rather than on the Water District
because I think in general um a
municipal or commercial activity has has
uh maybe a better m maintenance plan and
better resources to do this kind of
thing representative Dave thank you Mr
chair thank you representative for
taking my question so if these systems
are
mandated what would happen if somebody
in town refuses to put a system in is
there a penalty is there what would what
would happen yeah thank you for the
question so I think no I think you would
not be forcing somebody to do it I don't
know that I wrote it
um perfectly in that for that scenario I
think I said that the water system will
give them the system but you know maybe
they somebody won't let them in they
drop it off and it's there you know now
it's their problem so it's the same sort
of thing as if somebody built a house
and dug a well and just started drinking
the water and never put in a filter
right I mean you know that it's on them
basically
yep one one more thank you uh so so when
you when you test for Radon which I know
is totally separate it it's very
important that it's uh below a certain
number of curries per liter so
when you take a shower that that gets
emitted into the atmosphere would this
would you need that for your shower as
well that
filter yeah I'm I'm not qualified to
before we go around for a second
question from some of the
representatives I I had one question for
you you did mention in the beginning you
didn't make this specific to your town
in your District you made this to the
entire State just wanted to make sure I
was clear on that yes it's it's written
in in a general way any water district
well they would have to have a water
district right but it's any water
district but it could be any water
district that decides to do this yes
first representative neb then
representative Darby okay thank you for
taking my question again and this is
sort of I think I've wrapped my head
around what you're trying to do so bear
with me if I so you're essentially would
like to create a bifurcated path for
water for your water district where you
are providing non-potable water as a
water district people are now
responsible essentially once the
filtration system is installed for their
own portable water yes is that what
you're trying to do here okay and follow
up
it's quick does have you talked to your
water district about this I mean is this
something that they're supportive of or
do you have any sense of that yes I the
reason I'm I'm here is I was contacted
by the water district and they said $6
million you know it's
like and and and bills doubling and all
this sort of stuff right so can isn't
there some kind of alternative and and
at first I mean I'll tell you what they
want right they want somebody else to
pay the $6 million right right I mean
what would you expect right but you know
cuz I'm on the finance committee can't
you find us more money you know that
sort of thing and and the problem is we
don't have more money so this is an
alternative that that again it's it's it
creates an
alternative but but where right now
there is none basically you have to
spend the you know the Cadillac version
you know when maybe you want you know
the Hyundai version or something yeah so
representative
Derby thank you Mr chair thank you
representative McGuire for taking my
question looking at the water district
statutes you know there's an elected
Board of Commissioners and then it says
that the the municipalities um and
there's a set of criteria that they can
control um what what they can actually
charge to the water district and then
that the municipality is responsible for
budgeting one of the uh one of the
things given to the um authorities given
to the Commissioners is the ability for
direction of the of the water district
why can't they propose this as the
warrant article rather than having to
have a statute for it yes thank you for
the question again um just my
understanding from talking to Dees and
I'm sure they're here you can talk to
them yourself is that if my town refuses
the the solution that they offer then
they will simply shut down the water
district for having for not meeting
standards right and so and and therefore
give it to somebody else who will create
the standard you know will follow the
standards so we do need something to say
it's okay to be a little short of the
standards right at that point at the
point at which your water enters your
house but but you're not going to be shy
of the standards at the point you're
drinking the glass right so that's the
whole point of it Senator Ryan thank you
for thank you for taking my question the
water dist is the water district
responsible for providing portable water
to the
school yes thank you for the question
yes the water district does provide
water to the school current you know
again right now they're drinking 12
parts per trillion pasas right because
it's the wells right there
The Situation's in flux but um and and
by this bill it would then become the
responsibility of the
school essentially the water would be
unchanged right the water that's going
into the school would be the same water
it is now but but it would be up to the
school to fix it right for themselves
rather than the water district fixing it
if you see what I mean thank you
go again to representative Davis then
back to representative Taylor thank you
Mr chair and thank you Mr
mcguyer uh so so being new on this
committee forgive me if this is a silly
question but the cost of this is just to
the people inside the water district if
you have a private well and you're
outside of that area you don't have the
burden of this yes thank you for the
question but the answer is yes in in
every case it's only the water district
it's never the town that's going to pay
or anything like that it's the people
who are in the water are customers of
the water district so if for example
they went with you know and they could
vote to decide we want the $6 million
solution right and in that case because
the school is one of the customers of
this water their water bill is going to
double and so therefore the taxpayers of
the whole town would pay more for that
portion right so so
um only in that sense do people outside
the water district pay right but you
know that that's it should be
understandable thank you representative
Taylor thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking a question when will this
vote take place I thank you for the
question I think it's in March as part
elections let see any hands from the
representative
news she coming back to the well for the
think one more thank you Mr chair you
still didn't answer my question I'm
gonna let the chair decide whether I can
answer the question that's not right
sorry I paid almost $5,000 but Dees paid
for most of it um I I feel like if this
bill was to go forward the phrase the
legislative body needs to be clarified
that it's the district's legislative
because when I first read it I thought
it meant the state I don't know if any
if that's the issue anyone else had but
I just put that out
there yeah again that's thanks for the
question but that's the way it was
drafted and I think it's proper but I
could be
wrong and I'm not going to take any more
questions for representative thank you
very much appreciate you coming to us
thank you Mr chairman I'm sorry I have
to leave but my own committee's meeting
at this time yeah I know you had to
leave
out thank you chairman and members of
the committee I'm Brandon kernin I'm the
administrator of the drinking water and
groundwater Bureau at Dees and we're
here to testify on House Bill 44 9 um
one of the tasks of the bureau that I
administrate is to regulate public water
systems in the state and the govering
statutes uh really two sets um there's a
federal Safe Drinking Water Act and then
there's a state Safe Drinking Water Act
I would say the federal Safe Drinking
Water Act drives probably about 90% of
what we do with the state tweaking maybe
the other
10% um with represent Maguire is trying
to do it is to to be commended he's
trying to solve a very expensive problem
for people f um now that EPA now has a
standard of four parts of trillion that
we'll be enforcing in the future years
we could have up to half a billion
dollars in cost for Public Water Systems
across the state to comply you know
simply stated one in six people will be
drinking water over that standard in our
state and so it is a big cost
unfortunately the bill um House Bill 449
is not possible due to the federal Safe
Drinking Water Act um they have very
specific requirements on drinking water
quality standards for each end user be
it a business school or a Home the water
has to meet drinking water standards for
all those entities it has to be tested
on a regular basis the treatment systems
have to be maintained and overseen by
certified operators and so it it's just
not possible because it would violate
the federal uh statutes that we
administer also our state statutes right
now don't really have Provisions for
this either I will say I caveat that um
epa's Safe Drinking Water Act does allow
what they call point of use filter sort
of what representative McGuire is
talking about um but there are some very
strict standards that makes it so can
almost never be complied with
essentially every user of a water system
has to S sign an legal agreement that
the water system can enter their
facility maintain the filter install the
filter test the filter a couple times a
year and if one person that's part of
that system doesn't agree that's not an
option also although that filter may be
relatively inexpensive even if you
multiply by a factor of 100 or 300
initially think about past where you
have to test twice a year for $2 to $500
a sample again needing to get into
everyone's home so these point of use
regulations which New Hampshire is one
of the only few that have even adopted
across the states and I referenced it in
the letter um it's um EMV DW 720 3 are
only really good when you have really
small water systems like a 20 unit condo
or a 15 unit mobile home park and where
there can be bylaws that mandates anyone
living there allows access to the
building because again if that falls
apart all a sudden you fall out of
compliance and you're back to where you
were needing to put in centralized
treatment um represent mgu is right the
costs are high right now um but Water
Systems would be very smart to move
right now because um there's a lot of
loan forgiveness from the federal
government that will not be here in two
or three years so the time is now to
make these improvements even if they are
costly in the case of epson um he makes
a good point you know doubling the rate
from $400 a year to $800 a year is a big
change but 400 is really low water rate
to begin with and I'm not trying to
sound unsympathetic I know it's a big
jolt but a water rate to $800 a year is
Not Unusual or unreasonable across the
state to have safe drinking water it's a
lot cheaper than most people's annual
cell phone bills as far as the concept
of getting everyone off on the right
foot and having a filter installed as if
you're a private well owner and then
leaving it to the end user to maintain
that's problematic because experience
shows with private well users these
filters get quickly abandoned they don't
get tested because of the hundreds of
dollars and the logistics they don't
have vendors come out and service them
because it's expensive and inconvenient
or people forget about it in some
it's just it is implausible I guess the
last thing to mention that if it were
not for the federal MCL for past it
might have been possible to change state
law to allow this to be a remedy for
something we only have a state standard
for but that's not the case with past
anymore we have a federal standard so
it's not an option but that change would
need to occur in the Safe Drinking Water
Act I wouldn't recommend it I don't
think we think it's a good idea but as
it's proposed now it affect just water
districts and there's lots of different
Water Systems out there there's water
district there's Municipal systems
there's private homeowner associations
there you know all told there's 2500
different Water Systems to state that
fall into different types of categories
so the language would have to um change
I guess a couple other things we point
out in our letter that would want to be
addressed and if this was was even
possible but again it's not because it's
regulated at the federal level is who
installs the filter systems is important
um the bills talked about the filter
system providing two gallons a day that
might be enough for drinking water but
it doesn't talk about the capacity of
the filter how long it needs to last
that could be a little refrigerator
filter that lasts 30 days where you
clearly want something that would last
much longer than that and so for all
those reasons and even the public
notification requirements in here which
are redundant with we're already done
under the Safe Drinking Water Act um I
think you just want to consider those
things but again we don't take a
position because it's not going to
modify how we regulate water systems but
I just want to let you know some of the
inconsistencies and I don't think it'll
achieve the intended objective of
complying uh with the Safe Drinking
Water Act and avoiding the $6 million in
treatment
costs thank you any
questions representative Donnelly then
representative Derby thank you chair
thank you for taking my question
so I'm looking at this and saying who
enacts whether or not this happens is it
the is it the the town or is it the
person in the home that says we wanted
this I'm I'm unclear if this did pass if
this went through who says I get to
choose whether or not we are going to
either do a entire system that takes
care of all these Wells versus oh we're
going to give everyone um a filter who
makes that
decision how they comply with the ACT
ultimately is the water system's choice
but they can't choose an option that
doesn't comply with state and federal
law and so Dees if that was proposed to
us as a corrective action plan to put in
300 separate filters with no long-term
plan no legal agreements no testing
plans we would say that's insufficient
and you're still in
violation and to go to representative
McGuire's point about what happens if
you don't comply um since I've been at
the state for almost two and a half
decades at this point and I've only seen
us take receivership one time for a
water system you can talk to the
industry we work really hard with the
Water Systems to get cooperation it
might take a year two years figure out
creative funding packages But ultimately
a new well that's not contaminated
connection to another system nearby or
that treatment system away from the
flood plane would be the options um that
pursue thank you Mr chair uh thank you
for taking my question um when you say
that the passage of this law would not
affect um how you regulate Water Systems
which I think was what you said um
what do what does that mean um what does
it mean in terms of what how it would
apply to um you know Epsom who's trying
to mitigate this and would it still
result in for example taking
receivership so what would happen if
this passed is we would be separate of
all all this all these Provisions is in
a water district statute and we would
continue to administer RSA 45 and then
the federal Safe Drinking Water Act and
so there be
a series of enforcement steps ultimately
going to the Attorney General's office
with fines levied that could be enforced
by courts that the race payers would pay
and then if still nothing happened
receivership could happen but again as
I've at the state fines are very rare I
mean I it's like once every three or
four years out of 2 200 Water Systems I
think we actually f a water system
because the rate payers get educated
over time and will support the
investment in C Drinking Water Act
opposed to penalties over time um and
again receivership is really hardly on
the table it's once and 25 years that
I'm aware of it very
briefly very briefly one follow thank
you thank you Mr chair um just to help
me sort of do some research um what are
this this this section of the statute I
should look at for um you know where you
have to uh comply with it and and
ultimately potentially take receivership
um you know I understand how rare that
is but can you just point me to that
statue I can email you the exact
provision in the Safe Drinking Water Act
thank you very much answer your question
about the point of compliance for the
Safe Drinking Water Act it's the point
of entry of water into the water
distribution system so if you have a
well on this side and a well on this
side of the system and separate
treatment systems you're sampling right
the water right as it goes into the
distribution system and that's where the
point of compliance is measured under
Act representative Davis thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so there seems like a lot of moving
Parts here if every home has a
filtration system is is there any
opportunity for cross-contamination if
if somebody doesn't maintain their
system and their water falls below the
standard to siphoning for it to siphon
back into the rest of the system
contaminating other homes is that a
possibility
it's a possibility because you often
don't have backflow prevention
protection on homes more of a concern
probably be of an UNM system
unmaintained system is that it would be
building up with the contaminants you're
removing and if it gets the capacity it
starts releasing them and flakes so
you'll also release large doses of the
very thing you were trying to treat it
also becomes a bed for bacteria if it's
not replaced at some frequency even if
the water met standards coming from
sister it's a breeding ground for
bacteria if left alone too long one of
the treatment options for pest is carbon
carbon removes radon very well you can
create a radioactive field in your home
if you're not replacing that carbon
frequently enough and so maintenance is
really important I mean just to that
point we have radiation detectors at our
land Solid Waste
landfills and sometimes they go off and
it's almost always a water filter
inadvertently taking out Rong no one did
anything wrong but it it's what it does
so there's a lot that can go wrong and
it the water treatment system is the one
thing that can connect your clean water
drinking water to your Wastewater system
directly because you often have back
washer what have you and again in the
state and this is describing or letter
there's no real standards for who can
install a treatment system in the state
you have to be licensed to be a plumber
you have to be licensed to be a pump
installer you have to license to be
drill well but the one thing that
changes water quality you don't need a
license for and so if you don't have the
right air gap when you're putting in
that treatment system between waste
water and and the Clean Water um yeah
you no other questions for Mr
Karan seeing none thank you Mr Karan
appreciate it so I'll call I don't see
anybody else I don't have any other pink
cards is there anyone else to testify on
HB
449 anyone else to testify on HB 449
seeing nobody approaching the speaker
table I'll declare HB 449 hearing closed
and at 2:30 we'll open HB 513 relative
to snowmobiles and Trail connectors
thank
you the blue
sheet one
against okay thank you very much
represent
[Music]
okay so we're gonna wait for
them okay all right we'll wait a minute
we'll
get
e
marac 6 I serve on the house Ways and
Means Committee and I represent the
towns of Sutton and mment uh this house
bill 513 was drafted to address a a
10-year-old break now it's up to 14
years in the east to west landbridge
connection uh that was on an established
route before it's primary Trail
390 um I was contacted by the Sutton
Ridge Runners snowmobile club to help
seek relief and assistance in this east
to west or west to East blockage uh with
the
involvement
and I have been in discussion out here
with u uh
David rodrigue of
do
and the club had followed all the
regulations in trying to resolve this
and uh we we
feel that in discussion with the do that
maybe an amendment to this
bill would resolve the entire issue
because of maybe the way it's
two with the two uh highlights on uh the
first page under uh Roman numeral 7 uh
no request shall be necessary NE AR for
specific connectors authorized under the
RSA
23656 uh Roman numeral 2 F uh uh and the
last one not withstanding RS8 on Roman
numeral 5
25-c colon 8 the commissioner May
prescribe additional requirements for
operation on a right of way under
256 to
F the club was just mostly concerned
about
they've done all the work to get to the
stage where it would have moved forward
and they don't want to have to go back
through all the measurements all it
takes time for them they have to hire
people to get the exact measurements and
things that the application calls for
and they had it approved once and then a
private property owner uh said you can't
go across this Trail anymore this land
and so they were looking for a way to
get onto the RightWay and they didn't
want to have to measure the whole Trail
again so it's words that were the do is
concerned about how it's interpreted but
David has expressed the do has expressed
they can adjust and work with putting an
amendment here that they would be happy
with the New Hampshire uh Snowmobile
Association that went to their meeting
last night in
Tilton is fully in support of uh
correcting this uh and getting this done
and anything the committee can do any uh
amendments that would be added would
would be uh uh much appreciated and
um that's all I have on this
uh the bill was just it was a new
portion it was the on page
two the
amendment or the sub paragraph that was
inserted was to uh in our thinking in
the
beginning
uh this
disconnection uh uh was going to give
the dot more of a a way
to correct this without having to go
through the entire process of doing all
the paperwork again so um if you have
any questions fine but I think the do
team might be able to
answer ways to handle this so
representative just a heads up uh we're
going to be executing this in a week so
if you're getting amendments to us
sooner the better that's all and I saw
that schedule I said oh my gosh okay ERS
from above um anyone have any questions
for the representative representative
ghoul thank you for taking my question
and uh I'm on this efficiency thing I
mean myself not with important people
and uh it sounds as if you're trying to
make this more
efficient yes I am representative okay
you no other questions thank you
representative appreciate your
presentation thank you chairman har
welcome representative cluder also in
favor supporting the bill Mr chairman uh
and I just wanted to to reemphasize my
support for this bill and trying to
represent repres sham shamberg who
approached me I think partly because I'm
also on the the house Public Works and
highways committee and do is one of the
state agencies we work with the most and
I've always found them to be very
helpful and very flexible to try to work
with people provided they are legally
able to do it but this situation they
need some help from us uh in order to
solve this problem and I think if we
solve this problem we're going to help
the snowm bill industry which will also
help this the tourist in Industry
especially in the winter and I know I'm
come from Sullivan County by the way I'm
sorry didn't neglect to say I'm from
Sullivan County district 6 which
comprises the communities of Claremont
and Cy Claremont a small city of 13,000
croin about 800 people uh Sullivan
County altogether is maybe 45,000 one of
our smaller counties very rural so
there's a lot of tour you know as I said
they there's a lot of wooded area we
have a lot of
snowmobilers uh we only have i89 does
cross parts of Solen count I believe it
crosses parts of don't quote me cin I
know we don't have an interstate in
Claremont but I think this bill would be
very helpful if we could pass it I
realize it may have to be slightly
amended but I think we've got to to make
enable dot to help our snowmobile clubs
and and continue a thriving tourist
industry uh which will be very helpful
to the people and the businesses uh in
our state and again I please what I just
can't speak highly enough of dot which I
think is an efficient government agency
only about I think 1,600 employees if
I'm correct me if I'm wrong but they try
to be responsive whenever they can and
thank you very much for listening to me
thank you representative any questions
representative na thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question is
there any other example or precedent of
a RightWay being used in this way on a
state highway or off the top of my head
I can't think of any I but I can if it
gave me a maybe an hour or so I could go
back in my memory in my records I think
we've dealt with similar bills before
and I think we've always tried to to be
helpful with them uh you right a right
rways can be a touchy issue but I think
do in the end according to what I
understand it's not the federal
government it's the do2 who has
responsibility for maintaining these
these right of ways and so I think we've
got to pass some sort of legislation
like this bill to an able dot to do its
job to help the snowmobile
clubs any other questions for the
representative seeing none thank you
you from uh do David I'm gonna say this
R
welcome thank you Mr chair good
afternoon members of the committee um
so it seems like we have some agreement
to work on an amendment to this bill so
I will save my testimony that's prepared
for the bill as presented um but I'll do
two things the the first is I will go
back and see if we can find a way to
permit this without the legislation if
we need enabling
legislation and the representatives are
willing to work with us we will work
with them to have language that we think
helps um this is a difficult ult
situation for us because this connector
is on the interstate right of way which
as Federal Highway has informed them is
correct it's a do who owns a process to
permit that but we do need to prepare
information for federal highways
permission to do that the other thing I
just heard is it's potential that this
Trail may cross some state-owned Surplus
land
which has a legislative process that we
often need to go through in order to
cumber in incumber or dispose of or let
that state own land be used so I will
research those two things I'm hopeful we
can get to yes without any necessary
legislation and I'll take any questions
from the committee any
questions representative NB thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
is there a safety issue with um having
snowmobiles running parallel to a
highway there there can be safety issues
yes and that's one of the things that we
consider so for an interstate we're
fortunate to have a fair amount of land
from the edge of pavement to the edge of
the RightWay but as we look at that
we'll consider a couple of things
whether the RightWay fence needs to be
breached for for the trail to get on
there it's possible we can relocate that
to keep a continuous fence to help to
keep animals out of the RightWay we'll
also look at lights and the impact the
lights from the snowmobile could have on
the interstate traffic and any confusion
that could cause and we'll also look at
any maintenance issues that a trail
could cost cause so there are always
concerns but we're we're hopeful we can
mitigate them and the the reason we have
a process is because of those safety
concerns
yes representative uh
Bridal thank you chair and thank you for
taking my question um this parcel that
is uh denied access doesn't look like
there's any buildings on that but what
I'm more concerned with is that where
the rightaway is proposed I think of the
only other side of the
road snowmobile access is Route 11 I
think going up to through like Alton in
that area and they have Bridges and
stuff there that cross some water is
there any um concerns about for lack of
better turn infrastructure needs that
this I think it's a th000 foot section
would require is there any Bridges or
anything that needs to be built or is
this just a uh like a 10 foot dirt path
that's going to be straight through that
that's a good question that will be part
of our reviews um what I can say is um
dncr and the clubs are very Cooperative
with us if if any water Crossings or
anything needed they will provide that
as part of the the trail construction
and that's something will'll work
through um in a permitting
process representative Derby thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um so you mentioned um things
like the the study and you know possible
fencing changes and things like that is
is that money you already have in your
budget to to um make those changes if
needed that's something we would work
with dncr and the clubs um dncr has some
funds that go to the clubs and we would
typically be looking to the clubs to use
those grant and aid funds to um make
infrastructure any other
questions seeing none thank you
appreciate your testimony thank
you I don't have any more pink cards and
I don't see anyone approaching the table
yes okay as soon as I make sure there's
nobody else is there anybody else to
513 I won't go that fast I guess uh so
my name is Adam Schmid I'm a lobbyist
here in conquered and I do represent the
New Hampshire snowmobile Association uh
everything representative shamberg
conveyed to you earlier um was conveyed
to me by their executive director this
morning that said hey can you go pinch
hit for us at the house resources
committee um they're going to follow up
to with the committee with some written
testimony in support of the bill um
obviously the bill will have to be
tweaked based upon the testimony we've
heard so far I would trust do and and
representative shamberg to work through
that but just very briefly wanted to
make sure the committee was aware uh
nhsa is supportive of this effort to try
to solve this problem how we do it we're
open to whatever dot needs to make this
work but you will get some written
correspondents from the association
indicating their support for this thank
you very I probably can't answer any
questions about it okay so we won't ask
minute so last time I asked this we got
somebody else is there anybody else to
H will there's any further is
information I'll try to be at the exact
session I think next Wednesday just in
case when I will work with represent
something thank you for the
representatives it would be helpful to
us if you work with the do and they say
we can do this without it
um if you could send us a note and say
we don't need this legislation anymore
and the way I understand all the bills
we passed or didn't pass uh we'll still
bring it up for a vote and probably itl
it but um it would be nice if you told
us that in advance or here's the
amendment and then we'll bring the
amendment up at the exec session for a
vote okay thank you very much no one
else approaching I've asked three times
so I'm going to close HB 5113 and can I
ask the Republican in this committee to
you the green folders probably have